karina google ministra de desarrollo
internacional de canadá muchas gracias
por aceptar esta entrevista para radio
canadá internacional muchas gracias
canadá convocó a una reunión
recientemente del grupo de amigos por la
seguridad alimenticia y la nutrición
para discutir sobre las medidas que
podrían digamos de alguna forma
disminuir los efectos de la cob y de 10
en 19 en la disponibilidad de los
alimentos a través del mundo rápidamente
cuáles son las con cuáles son las
conclusiones a las que llegaron en este
en esta reunión que es cuáles son las
acciones que se van a tomar y cuál es la
postura canadiense particularmente en
ese tema sí gracias por la pregunta y
esa reunión fue muy importante a
convocar para subrayar la importancia al
acceso de la comida para la gente en
situaciones vulnerables alrededor del
mundo te escuchamos de
a las cabezas de varias organizaciones
internacionales enfocados en este tema
quienes nos contaron a las
preocupaciones por ejemplo este el
programa mundial de alimentación da
comida a 100 millones de personas cada
año y eso es nada más en el contexto
humanitaria normal eso no incluye los
que necesita este apoyo adicional por
cuestiones del cob y también escuchamos
de los 370 millones de niños que
dependen sobre ese programa para recibir
comidas de la escuela y 80 y 2.5 por
ciento de los niños en el mundo no están
actualmente en la escuela entonces
estamos trabajando con el programa de
alimentación mundial para ver a este
cómo ellos pueden trabajar con gobiernos
nacionales para ver otros puntos de
distribución esté comprometimos todos
los que participamos que fue convocado
con italia brasil egipto
con la participación de la mayoría de
los miembros de la onu que vamos a
enfocar en ese tema para tratar de
evitar una crisis alimentaria y antes
con medidas y apoyando al programa este
de alimentación mundial es una manera
muy importante de hacer eso también te
comprometimos de guardar abiertas las
fronteras este por cuestiones de cambio
de cambio de comercio exterior para
asegurar que todavía las cadenas de
comida de cuestiones básicas
pueden seguir cruzando fronteras y
estamos muy preocupados de los países
por ejemplo que son islas pequeñas que
dependen mucho sobre la importación de
comida y también países que no tienen
acceso al mar que están la realidad es
que están en rodeado de otros países
en mucho el comercio exterior para este
su soberanía de comida lo que acaba de
decir me hace pensar justamente en la
siguiente pregunta que es con respecto a
américa latina y particularmente el caso
de bolivia que no tiene acceso a las
costas que sea que cuáles son los
proyectos en américa latina particular
pues éste canadá está apoyando la
organización panamericana de salud a que
están llevando las de la respuesta en
américa latina y en el caribe de
cuestiones de salud eso es una de las
cosas que estamos haciendo estamos
preocupados por ejemplo en el caribe y
otros países que dependen mucho del
turismo porque sabemos que pues están
las ganancias del turismo o sea ya ya no
existen en este momento y muchos de esos
gobiernos éste requieren esas ganancias
para mantener sus servicios al público
entonces estamos trabajando con el
caricom y con otras regiones
otras organizaciones regionales para
asegurar que ellos reciben
las cosas que necesitan y también este
la oea por ejemplo el fin de semana este
tuvo una reunión extraordinaria para su
respuesta regional al cob y entonces
estamos trabajando directamente con
algunos países pero también este por
medida de las asociaciones regionales
tanto de salud tanto política para
trabajar y entender las necesidades de
los países en la región y responder
adecuadamente
a nadar recientemente apoyó el llamado
del secretario de naciones unidas para
un cese del fuego en todo el mundo
durante la pandemia le quería preguntar
y también concluyó un acuerdo con arabia
saudita abriendo digamos la posibilidad
a la venta de armas por parte de canadá
hacia árabes ahorita hay alguna
contradicción en estas dos posturas
ministra pues este nosotros estamos
apoyando
la llamada del secretario general de iu
a bajar las armas de este y eso es súper
importante en el contexto del cobi 19
porque sabemos que en las situaciones de
conflicto esté la posibilidad de
transmisión del cob y 19 es aún más más
grande por cuestiones de está más
difícil identificar casos es más difícil
este aislar la gente es más difícil este
tratarlos cuando están enfermos
también sabemos que la gente que viven
actualmente en situaciones de conflicto
la mayoría de ellos no tienen acceso a
la salud de misma manera estoy pensando
por ejemplo en yemen y en siria es de
donde los sistemas de salud han sido
este muy lastimados por las cuestiones
de conflicto entonces apoyamos
fuertemente esa llamada con respecto a
la venta de armas es el gobierno de
canadá ha realizado un estudio bastante
amplio en en ese sentido para asegurar
que esas armas no están esté usados con
en situaciones donde hay una un impacto
sobre los derechos humanos y este mi
colega al ministro de relaciones
exteriores ha confirmado que si canadá
tiene alguna duda o ve que son
utilizados en acciones que contribuyeron
a una pérdida de una infracción contra
los derechos humanos que éste dejará de
seguir con las ventas
karina google del desarrollo
internacional de canadá muchas gracias
por esta entrevista muchas gracias hasta
luego hasta luego